things you missed in blood-borne exists
to tell you the things you need to know
about a stage for a boss or the story
nothing more than what's essential I
mean if this was an unedited walkthrough
I would have to show you how I got stuck
in between these cabinets and couldn't
get out for 20 minutes let's not do that
that wasn't funny I had to kill myself
and I lost all my blood echoes that's
number one by the way don't walk in
between the cabinets but let's start as
we all must at the beginning after
you've created your unspeakable
abomination in the character creator you
don't actually have to kill the werewolf
in the next room or die to it it only
drops two blood vials the best thing to
do is actually just to run past it and
try and get to the first messenger
lantern this way you spend less time
warping between areas and less time
looking at that blood-borne loading
screen if you return to the clinic after
entering the hunters dream you can talk
to yourself cut who's locked herself in
the room where you spawned before
release many thought that the man who
gave us the blood transfusion was Yosef
qey but actually it's this kind woman
caring for the afflicted if you find
anyone else in the world who needs a
safe place to stay then later in the
game you should keep this place in mind
as you make your way through the world
you're likely to encounter this
executioner and instead of encounter I
suppose I mean die too because he's
brutally difficult for a new player the
best strategy is to shoot your gun as
soon as you see him start an attack
animation that's how fast his attacks
are more often than not he'll knock him
on to his knees if you follow this
strategy but the weird thing about this
guy is that he's one of the few enemies
that drops something other than blood
vials or bullets about 50% of the time
he'll drop a tempering blood gemstone
after you get the right workshop tool
you can put three of these gemstones
onto your weapon and they buff your
weapon in different ways
I believe this one makes your physical
attacker eyes and if you find a
particularly rare tempering gemstone
then it increases the damage you do when
your health is full as well you can see
the rarity of this stone here so it's
worth farming this executioner to get a
good gemstone next I need to tell you
about the fastest possible way to unlock
the shortcut in
from yharnam unlocking this shortcut is
essential if you want a quick run to the
first boss we're aiming to unlock this
gate to the left of the lantern so you
start off running past the hunt they
won't follow you if you run fast enough
and then as soon as you lose them hug
the left wall you'll see a bunch of
wooden coffins here and a couple of them
are hiding a gap in the fence jump down
here to the dog cage area and instead of
going forward to the sewers go back
you're looking for a door at this point
you want to go through it and then
you're in the dark house when you're in
the dark house you go through the
opposite door and continue up to unlock
the shortcut this lets you bypass pretty
much the entire level and from start to
finish you can get to unlocking the
shortcut in less than a minute that said
you should probably do the level
normally there's some great items in
here and you do actually want to get
good at the game don't you in particular
one item you need is the torch that the
brick troll is guarding to take him out
you just time a gunshot just before he
strikes you his attacks are really slow
if you keep your distance if you stand
too close to him his attacks are really
fast so back up and shoot him when he's
about to hit you when you walk past him
at first it looks like he doesn't notice
you but don't be fooled if you ignore
him
he'll come up behind you and ambush you
while you're fighting the next group of
enemies don't ask how I found that one
out the next choke point for a lot of
people is going to be fighting these two
werewolves if you're having trouble with
it don't worry I've got some cheese for
you simply run past them then take the
first stairs you see on the left be
careful of this guy
then enter the dark house kill the two
enemies on the top floor then turn
around and see the two where will stuck
in this door it's very easy to poke them
with an extended weapon here until
they're dead and then you can explore
the bridge at your leisure alternatively
Molotov cocktails are a good way to take
them out if you don't like the cheese
before you fight the werewolves there is
an entrance to the sewers off to the
left side of the bridge through all of
this debris in my opinion it's the
easiest and best way down to the sewers
especially because it leads you to the
hunters attire this set is undoubtedly
better than the one you start with so
it's a good way to start your journey
into the sewers and when you make this
large drop down to the legless towns
you should immediately look for a ladder
and head up eventually you'll come up
behind the house that had music coming
from it some of you might remember that
and you can talk to this young yharnam
girl in the litt window the music box
she gives you will help you with a boss
fight later on and also you guys should
prepare to cry it's kind of sad if you
continue down in the sewers you'll
eventually spot epic named bro at the
end of this tunnel he'll scream at you
but this gives you a chance to get
behind him without being charged and one
shot in the tunnel so get behind the pig
and you will have time to charge up our
two and initiate a critical it does a
lot of damage but [ __ ] was that really
worth it
turns out yeah it's worth it after that
traumatizing vision you should go behind
the pig to loot the saw hunters patch
which lets you buy all the starting
weapons from the messengers in the bath
up the ladders from the pig you'll
arrive at another bridge across the
bridge is a second boss near here is an
elevator you're going to want to
activate it so you can have a fast run
back to this boss because oh boy you
guys are gonna be running to this boss a
lot the second boss is not easy going
back do you remember the Caged dogs we
drop down to when we were doing the
shortcut this leads the second entrance
over the sewers along this path there's
this old lady hiding from the beasts
she's looking for a safe place to stay
so store that information away for later
when you find her a safe haven further
on there's a hidden entrance to the
rafters to the right here cut down these
two hanging corpses the one on the left
has the saw spear weapon which is an
alternate version of this saw cleaver
and the one on the right has a bunch of
bloodstone shards and that's pretty much
it for the interesting things in central
yharnam I missed out on a few
consumables but I want to leave the rest
for you guys to explore I can't wait to
hear how you're all going with the game
so let me know it's so much fun isn't it
the combat is so fast
the regain system works so well the
bosses are so creative I've actually
spent more time making videos than
playing at this point so I think I'm
gonna go and play some more now if you
need help with the first two bosses
I'll have episodes out on them soon you
might be wondering about my plan for
blood-borne in regards to guides and it
depends on your feedback
you can see how it go but right now I
think I'm going to be doing things you
missed four areas because learning about
things you missed in an area makes more
sense than going through every little
bit of the area and for bosses I'm going
to be putting out short boss guides that
give you the most important ways to beat
them so let me know what you think of
that let me know what you think of this
video leave a like if you learned
something new and if there's anything
you think I missed I've actually left a
link in the description for the extra
life wiki for this area if you go there
you can edit the page and add your own
tips for central yharnam this is a
pretty good idea for these videos right
it means we can all contribute to the
community knowledge and if I do miss
something which I will you guys can add
it yourself and help everybody out I'm
hoping this will make the resources
around the game even better if you need
help with the two bosses then check out
the dream guides to come on my channel
and see you guys soon thanks for
watching
[Music]